Transcriptor: DD Chang
Revisor: Analia Padin
Pensemos en un verbo que pueda funcionar
como sinónimo exacto de cuidar.
¿Cual sería?
¿Defender?
¿Preservar?
¿Proteger?
¿Vigilar?
¿Amar?
Si seguimos ampliando esta lista
podemos llegar a algunas certezas.
Primero, que todos esos verbos
en conjunto y simultáneamente
son sinónimo de cuidar.
Después, que todas y todos,
a cada paso estamos realizando acciones
y tomando decisiones
que tienen que ver con esos verbos.
Finalmente, que también recibimos
acciones y decisiones
por parte de otras personas que entran
en este campo semántico de cuidar.
Porque sin cuidados no estaríamos aquí.
Porque cuidar sostiene la vida.
Pero ¿de qué hablamos
cuando hablamos de cuidar?
Si yo vengo aquí
a decirles que la respuesta
es que cuidar sostiene la vida,
me podrían reclamar
que es una respuesta tramposa
porque en realidad lleva a más preguntas.
Y tendrían razón.
Entonces puedo darles una definición.
Por ejemplo, la que consignan
María Ángeles Sallé y Laura Molpeceres
para ONU Mujeres.
Dice:
"Los cuidados son las actividades
que, a diario y por generaciones,
regeneran el bienestar físico
y emocional de las personas".
Al seguir el hilo de esta definición
podemos vislumbrar actividades
que entran en ella:
la procuración de los cuerpos,
de la salud, de los bienes,
de los espacios, del apoyo psicológico,
la contención emocional, la educación,
la formación, la maternidad.
Lo que todavía no sé
es si todas y todos sentimos
que esta definición
nos interpela directamente,
si la consideramos un asunto vital.
Yo vengo aquí a decirles
que sí es un asunto vital
y que cada una y cada uno tenemos
un lugar en esta conversación,
en esta propuesta,
en esta revolución de los cuidados.
Para eso necesito pedirles
que escuchen y admitan,
al menos durante el tiempo
que dura esta charla, cuatro premisas
que nos van a ayudar a pensar en conjunto
de qué hablamos cuando hablamos de cuidar.
Primera premisa:
nuestros cuerpos vivos son
los primeros testigos de los cuidados
porque cuidar sostiene la vida.
Si somos personas vivas es
porque nos han cuidado y nos cuidan;
no hay de otra.
El problema viene cuando
la relación con la vida
está mediada por factores
muy conflictivos.
Nos han dicho que la vida
hay que ganársela,
que hay que rascarse con las propias uñas.
Y cuando somos personas tristes,
personas cansadas, personas asustadas,
violentadas, exaustas,
¿cuál es nuestra relación con la vida,
esa que siempre parece pintada
de colores brillantes, inalcanzable?
Si la vida entra en estándares
en los que nunca es suficiente
tampoco los cuidados lo serán.
Este mundo nos obliga a disociarnos.
Yo y mi cuerpo, yo y mi vida;
como si fueran cosas separadas.
Pero no lo son.
Lo cierto es que si queremos activar
un filtro para ver a los cuidados,
pero de veras verlos,
lo primero que podríamos hacer
es consultar con nuestro cuerpo.
Él nos sabrá orientar.
Segunda premisa:
ya tenemos marcos desde los cuales
podemos mirar a los cuidados
y proponer a partir de ello.
Si eso del cuerpo les parece todavía
abstracto, no se preocupen.
Hay muchas personas
que durante años han trabajado
para vincular los marcos ya conocidos
a esta conversación sobre los cuidados.
En México,
el INEGI tiene una encuesta
de la que se deriva
que los trabajos no remunerados
que se hacen en los hogares y familias
aportan 23 % al producto interno bruto.
Y en otros países la cifra es muy similar.
Ese es un dato fuerte, duro,
que nos destraba la conversación.
Allí está la estadística de los cuidados.
Hay una comunidad en Australia
que se llama "Crystal Waters".
En ella, las casas
están construidas de tal manera
que la iluminación y la ventilación
dependen absolutamente
del entorno natural.
Y al interior, las paredes tienen
orificios estratégicamente puestos
para que el polvo no se acumule,
lo que deriva no solamente
en un mejor cuidado de la salud
sino también en menores
estándares de limpieza.
Ahí está la arquitectura en los cuidados.
En esta pandemia ha circulado
una infografía en la que nos dicen
la manera correcta de lavarnos
las manos, paso por paso,
porque parece que no lo
estábamos haciendo tan bien.
Esto nos permite pensar que
quizás los cuidados
no son un asunto de buenas intenciones,
sino de adquirir conocimientos,
actitudes, habilidades
que nos permitan procurar
de una mejor manera la propia vida
y la de las otras personas.
Ahí están las ciencias
de la salud en los cuidados.
Cuidar parece abstracto
porque es transversal
y como no iba a serlo
si la vida también lo es.
Por eso es que hay aproximaciones
desde la ética, desde la sociología,
desde la literatura, desde la linguística;
cada marco, cada ámbito,
cada persona viva
puede aportar algo
a esta conversación
sobre los cuidados.
Todo comienza con afirmar
con plena convicción:
"Yo cuido, a mí me cuidan".
Y llevar eso más allá
de nuestros espacios privados.
Poner el cuidado en el centro,
lo primero que hace
es cambiar la forma de mirar.
Después, la forma de pensar.
Finalmente, la forma de actuar.
Tercera premisa:
el mundo, tal como está estructurado,
se resiste con todas sus fuerzas
a que los cuidados sean el centro.
Así como ya tenemos marcos conocidos
de los que podemos ver a los cuidados
y proponer a partir de ello,
también hay que reconocer
los límites de esos marcos,
cuándo dejan de ser funcionales.
Por ejemplo, desde la perspectiva
económica y política
poner sobre la mesa la palabra "trabajo"
para hablar de esto es muy importante.
Porque permite ver con toda claridad
que los cuidados no son un asunto natural,
no son arte de magia,
sino que son sujetos
de derechos laborales,
de marcos legales y de remuneración.
Porque en realidad las personas
que han hecho históricamente
estas actividades
han sido las más vulnerables.
¿Quién está cuidando a quienes sostienen
nuestras vidas en lo más esencial?
¿Qué reciprocidad estructural
están recibiendo?
Ahora, una vez puesta sobre la mesa
la palabra "trabajo",
vemos que tampoco resuelve todo.
Las personas que están profesionalizando
los cuidados no están recibiendo
una remuneración que les permita
sostener sus propias vidas,
ni a sus familias, ni ahorrar,
ni garantizarse una vejez tranquila.
Luego, volteamos a ver
todos los otros trabajos
y resulta que tampoco están garantizando
esas condiciones mínimas.
Resulta que la palabra "trabajo",
en este mundo,
está asociada con precariedad,
con condiciones extenuantes,
con angustia,
con explotación.
Y ahí es donde necesitamos
añadir a la conversación
todo aquello que no está,
pero necesitamos que esté.
Lo que no existe
porque lo vamos a construir.
La imaginación es parte esencial
en la revolución de los cuidados.
Cuarta premisa:
no podemos seguir hablando de cuidados
si no nos detenemos
a aprender de las personas,
en su gran mayoría mujeres,
que dedican su vida
a sostener las vidas.
De nuestras ancestras,
aprendemos que cuidar
significa tener el cuerpo puesto.
Necesitamos recuperar
ese carácter presencial y comprometido
sin que ello signifique
que tantas mujeres, literalmente,
sigan dejando el cuerpo ahí.
De las mujeres que maternan,
aprendemos que cuidar
implica una gestión de tiempos,
de espacios, de energías.
Preguntarse qué es
lo verdaderamente importante
en estos términos
de sostenimiento de la vida
y aceptar que esa vida
que se está sosteniendo
también es capaz de tomar
sus propias decisiones.
Urge recuperar toda esa inteligencia
y hacer algo con ella como sociedad.
Como dice Marcela Lagarde:
"desmaternizar a las mujeres
para maternizar a la sociedad".
Porque el cuidado nos conecta
de una manera totalmente distinta
con nuestra propia vida.
De las cuidadoras profesionales
y las trabajadoras del hogar,
aprendemos que cuidar no es solamente
adquir saberes técnicos y manuales
sino también afectivos,
emocionales, vitales.
Necesitamos desnaturalizar los cuidados
y dejar de alimentar estándares salvajes
que solamente precarizan cada vez más
a los cuerpos que cuidan.
Esas son las cuatro premisas.
Nuestros cuerpos vivos son
los primeros testigos de los cuidados.
Ya tenemos marcos desde los cuales
podemos mirar el sostenimiento de la vida
y proponer a partir de ello.
El mundo, tal como está estructurado
se resiste a que los cuidados
sean el centro.
Necesitamos aprender de las personas,
en su gran mayoría mujeres,
que dedican su vida a sostener las vidas.
Si las añadimos a nuestro filtro
para mirar el mundo,
podremos, en un futuro que espero
que no sea muy lejano,
regresar a esta conversación y responder
con una respuesta construida en común
a la pregunta fundamental:
¿de qué hablamos
cuando hablamos de cuidar?
Entonces sabremos cuál es
el siguiente paso,
porque será un paso
que daremos en colectiva.
Aprendamos a diario y por generaciones
a sostener el bienestar físico
y emocional de las personas.
Incorporemos a nuestro trayecto vital,
no solamente "Yo cuido, a mí me cuidan",
sino "Yo aprendo a cuidar".
"Yo reconozco a quienes me cuidan".
"Yo necesito que me cuiden".
"Yo necesito cuidar".
Otra vez.
"Yo aprendo a cuidar".
"Yo reconozco a quienes me cuidan".
"Yo necesito que me cuiden".
"Yo necesito cuidar".
Una vez más.
"Yo aprendo a cuidar".
"Yo reconozco a quienes me cuidan".
"Yo necesito que me cuiden",
Yo necesito cuidar".
Muchas gracias.